well welcome to everyone it's really
very exciting occasion and mr. Prime
Minister it's such a thrill to have you
here at Yale and have you here on our
faculty teaching our students who just
completed your first class I know and to
rave reviews and it's it's very exciting
for our whole community to welcome you
here to New Haven to participate in the
life of Yale thank you they were a
little smart actually we thought so we
thought so too so why don't we kick this
off you know when I when we first
started talking about this engagement
and talking about the possibility of
your coming here to embark on a program
and faith and globalization I have to
say I was inspired but also also sort of
surprised by your courage in taking on a
topic it meant that many people would
think so intractable as you know using
religion as a force for good in the
world as opposed to a force for division
and so maybe maybe you'd like to tell us
kind of what got you inspired to do this
what what motivated you to start a
program and faith in globalization what
festival I should say that when I was
Prime Minister and you got advice from
the the top civil servants and when they
thought you were doing something really
really stupid they would say that's an
immensely courageous thought Prime
Minister
ayuh planet but it is it is a little
ambitious let's say I think it's because
I I saw in the work that I I did in
government but also my own personal
experience that religious faith
motivates people very strongly and it
can motivate them to do great good as it
has done in many parts of the world and
alleviating poverty and helping the less
fortunate and in great acts of
compassion but it can also be a reason
for conflict and division and
sectarianism and violence and we've seen
the two sides of religion if you like
over the past decade and I the the
theory that I have which I was exploring
with the students today is that
globalization is basically a force that
pushes people together and if religion
becomes a force that pulls people apart
then it becomes actually a threat to the
way the 21st century works on the other
hand I think the globalization is
improved by the values that come with
proper spiritual faith and if we have
the right values it will allow us to
make globalization work for all people
and not just for elites or for a small
number so what concretely what would you
what do you hope to accomplish through
this exercise of teaching here and
promulgating some of these ideas I mean
I hope what we can do is is devise a
course that we can take out from Yale
and do in different parts of the world
where we explore the different
relationship between faith and
globalization the different strands of
it I hope too that we we will get a
whole lot of work and research done
around the topic so that we understand
it better and from the you know from the
start we had today it's going to be a
lively they're really clever these
students you going
I mean I I felt terrible because I was I
was telling them all that that I was not
a distinguished student I thought I'd
get my humility in first before the
inadequacy became all too evident and I
was telling him that the very when I was
at University and I read law which I'm
afraid I didn't read very well and there
was a time about 18 months into my time
at university and I was standing around
some John's College Oxford and this this
this this older guy came up to me and
said hello he said let me introduce
myself you don't know me and I said no I
don't actually
and he said that I am the person who's
been giving the lectures for the last
six months that you supposed to be in
attending if you can fit me into your
busy schedule like be very grateful so
but I I hope we can make this this
course something as I say that is not
just gonna be a value to Yale but that
we can take out to different parts of
the world that's great you you cured me
by mentioning introductions of course
should have started by introducing my
fellow panelists to my left it looks
like the right to you is Paul Kennedy J
Richardson Dilworth professor of history
and one of the co-inventors of Yale's
remarkable grand strategy program and to
his left is leta Tandon who is
representing a very large and diverse
group of students at Yale and I'm sure
she doesn't speak for everyone but he is
the executive director of global 21
which is the umbrella organization which
were very proud that started here at
Yale with the publication of the Yale
globalist magazine and spread to ten of
the great universities of the world
where sister publications are are now
published regularly all over the world
including the Cambridge University in
England so glad to have professor
Kennedy and leave a tandon with us today
mr. Kennedy yes what we thought we would
do in the next while attorney is
who asked you to reflect on a number of
really difficult Rick said intractable
or near intractable problems that you
grappled with in your time as Prime
Minister and to in some cases perhaps
grappled with faith or some cases just
because they were politically innocent
necessary and the first topic we wanted
to ask you about was a reflection on
your grappling with see 300 year old
plus problem of Northern Ireland of
Ulster of this terrible conflict of went
on century after century between
Protestant and Catholic now as a
historian I know that every British
prime minister has said oh I've got to
pay some attention to the Northern
Ireland problem and then after a few
months said well just god I don't know
how to deal with it very much because
you can't do anything you persisted year
after year was quite number of setbacks
and I'd like you to reflect another I've
always wondered whether it was a faith
driven rather than just a political
expediency need to do something
motivation on your part for the solution
of the Ulster problem
well actually was in part circumstance
driven in in this sense and I think this
is the the important thing about the way
the world works today and essentially my
views the world is now changing very
very fast indeed and what that does is
that throws up a whole lot of problems
but what it can also mean is that things
that seem intractable can be solved and
in my view of the Northern Ireland
situation was that a dispute within
quite a small bit of territory between
Catholic and Protestant as you approach
the 21st century is absurd
so I started from irrational I mean not
very sensible in the world of politics I
know but I started from a just a
rational perspective this thing should
be able to be resolved and because the
people in the south of Ireland and the
people in Britain could see that in the
world that was developing with the
European Union and the global economy
what they had in common was infinitely
more important than as I say a division
between Catholic and Protestant I think
what I learnt from it in the course of
doing it and we almost stumbled into the
Good Friday Agreement I mean I I've
never really put it like this before and
it's it's it's it's an odd thing but
actually we had negotiated the Good
Friday Agreement when we were supposed
to go and have a meeting for a day which
turned into a meeting for four days and
to be absolutely honest that by the end
of the fourth day it kind of became too
embarrassing not to do the deal because
all the press were camped outside and
everyone was sort of you know they must
be doing something in there
and I remember it was also very
interesting for me because my um
actually I was supposed to go and see
that the prime minister of Spain at the
time and said we were supposed to finish
on the first day right and my family
were going to spend time with his family
so my family went on ahead so by the
time I actually got to Spain
four days later he'd had my entire
family including my mother-in-law there
for about four days
and which brought us very close together
what I learned above all else from that
process was that if you want to solve
these conflicts and I happen to think
there are parallels with the Middle East
here you have to be prepared to focus
and dedicate and commit 100% you know
you have to pay attention to the detail
you have to go right into the depths of
it and you have to understand that if
the two sides have been able to solve it
themselves they would have done it the
fact that they happen means that they
won't on their own and you know what I
take from that into my new role in the
Middle East is that you need to focus on
this as as I say in this committed way
and you need to make sure that we're not
as it were just letting them get on with
it but we're actively trying to build
the peace with the full resource of the
outside community as well as the inside
community and and the final thing I
learned was that when I first began this
I cannot tell you how many people said
to me this is stupid because they hate
each other you've got to understand they
hate each other they always have and
they always will
and by the end of it by creating a peace
process with the space within which
people could could start to work with
each other and talk with each other and
learn about each other you then get to
the situation where today you have the
Reverend Ian Paisley and Martin
McGuinness sitting down in government
together and getting on with a
camaraderie that is quite frightening to
behold and if anyone had said 20 years
ago 10 years ago that that would have
happened they would have been certified
so so here's my follow-up to this if I
looked at what you were doing when I did
live in what you were doing at the
beginning I thought this is crazy the
chances are a hundred to one
we're probably now in danger of saying
they were just waiting for this wise
external force to come along and in
retrospect compared with the other
problems of the world
it was controllable space they weren't
external spoilers and therefore as we
pass on to Iraq and other parts of
Middle East what's going to be an sword
in my mind is it is the solution of the
also problem going to look the easy one
compared with some much much deeper and
more intractable as we now see you were
going to ask about Iraq I was actually
curious about Iraq as professor Kennedy
said the situation in Iraq you drew
parallels to the Middle East but also
Iraq is a similar situation that where
conflict requires some sort of
intervention and now with the gift of
hindsight with the trans to see what the
global community's reaction was would be
what the economic repercussions were of
the war would you have done anything
different in 2003 is where you end up
dividing the audience in to me in a
small number and the rest
I think the first of all you know you've
got to pay attention to the enormous
consequences of what has happened I mean
in terms of life and death and and cost
the second thing however is that I think
what happened in Iraq can be can be
fitted into two stages one was the stage
of removing the original regime there
and the other is what has happened
subsequent to that time and I mean I see
that I may be wrong I mean I don't I
don't say that I've got any greater
wisdom than anyone else it's just that
when you're a decision maker in the end
you've got to make a decision I
personally believe that what has been
happening in Iraq for the past five
years or more since the removal of
Saddam is actually part of the same
picture happening all over that region
which is people the majority trying to
be part of the modern world and then a
small minority through the use of
terrorism and the provocation of chaos
and instability trying to prevent the
country making progress and what has
been happening in Iraq over the past few
years is now what is happening in
Afghanistan today I see it in the Middle
East with the palestinian-israeli
situation I mean the truth is if you
stopped I do not support all the actions
of Israel let me make that clear but the
truth is if you stopped the terrorism
you could resolve the
israeli-palestinian issue reasonably
quickly now that is not to excuse
everything that Israel does do not
misunderstand me by any shape or form
but the fact of that terrorism is what
causes a situation in which Israel feels
it has to occupy the West Bank in order
to protect it
against the terrorist threat likewise
when you go to Lebanon you find the same
forces that play and therefore my view
of Iraq is that it's not enough but you
know you might say well he would say
this wouldn't he
it's not enough to say this has been
more bloody and difficult and costly
than ever we expected you half also to
ask the question why you know and why is
it that these people have decided to
move in in this way and visit this
destruction and my point about that is
that they are the same forces that we're
fighting everywhere and therefore if you
I'm afraid in my view if you yield to
them in one place you will end up
yielding to them in another and I think
there is a sense in which we in our own
countries don't get the full strength of
this alternative narrative within Islam
about how the West is in opposition to
Islam and how this is a fundamental
struggle that can only have one victor
in it and it is almost impossible to see
from outside until you go inside and you
just see the depth of of this feeling
that there is and my own view of this is
that if we want to to change this
situation we have to change it by
looking at the region of the Middle East
and the world of Islam as a whole and
you may find this curious for me to say
you will not deal with this threat
because it is a threat simply by
military means we are going to have to
have the right body of ideas of
empowering moderate and modern people
within Islam the right
injustice the right belief in hope and
equality in order to make sure that as
well as dealing with the symptom of this
problem we also deal with its root
causes deep within the world of Islam
and I can tell you this from the
perspective the work I do in the Middle
East I do not think there is anything
more important and so if we were able to
produce peace between Israel and
Palestine the effect would be not just
that the violence in that part of the
world would stop but it would be a
symbol of peaceful coexistence that
would then reverberate throughout the
entirety of Islam undermining the
narrative of the extremists and
supporting the narrative of the moderate
and modern people but it's when I look
at Iraq today I see that the tragedy and
the waste of human life of course but I
also see it not as an inevitable
consequence of removing Saddam but as a
deliberate consequence of these
self-same people that we are fighting
everywhere trying to prevent the
ordinary people in Iraq having the
future that they want they're really
sound that Universalist when you say you
can't fight them in just one place we
have to it's its global it's its
universal so that means you can't
arrange your priorities and say well
they might be active or arising in
Indonesia but that's less pertinent to
us or less of a threat you you really do
think this is well I guess like
President Bush but it is something which
has to be met with thought about and if
necessary challenged everywhere yeah but
you can challenge in different ways and
this I think is important for example
one of the things I did before I left
office as Prime Minister is I signed an
agreement with the Pakistani government
to invest hundreds of millions of pounds
in their education system so that we
gave
young people in Pakistan the opportunity
of education without having that done
exclusively in some of the extreme
religious madrassas so you don't have to
deal with this all by military means
sometimes you may have to and you can
debate whether that's right or wrong in
each individual case but in the end if
we are sensible about this we will
understand this is a global movement
with an ideology and the only way of
defeating that in the end is through a
better idea
not through the force of weapons it'll
be through the force of ideas and that's
why it's important the reason why it's
important that we have justice for
Palestinian people is that if we do
deliver justice for them that is a sign
that our ideology is not based on
Christian or American values but based
on universal values that should be open
to people of non-christian faith and
people outside of America as well as
Christians living inside America and
that universal sense about our values is
fundamental so they can expose connects
the work in the seminar here to a major
solution presumably rillette are you
saying relating to the modern and
moderate elements within Islam and
bringing them into a conversation yeah
makes them look if you were if you're a
Muslim living out in the Middle East at
the moment
you will see very clearly the two
different strains within Islam and what
is essential is that those people who
believe in peaceful coexistence and they
in my view are the true representatives
of Islam succeed and we've got to help
them do that we could I really do have
to if I may put you on the spot
why not you do it very courteously bull
or at least up denounces it may well be
that despite the efforts on the civilian
front any education front and the
cultural front decisions have to be made
about not scattering your eggs military
eggs and military resources around him
in too many baskets and as you know
there's there's really interesting
debate on both sides of the Atlantic
about whether Iraq ultimately is more
soluble and more significant than
Afghanistan and the experts are out all
over the place and there's six arguments
to be made for Afghanistan being more
important ultimately especially for
Britain with opium poppy trade etc as
opposed to Iraq and Anatolia reasons why
Iraq is terribly important do you come
down on that at all oh you really think
we need to do both and one would if one
fell or one was conceded the other would
be harmed first of all I think these are
really difficult questions and therefore
I don't you know one of the things I
always tried to say to people about this
is that there are lots of people I know
whose judgment I respect that took a
different view and that take a different
view so all I can give you is my view
but I give it with deference and I give
it with it with a certain amount of
humility but I think there are two
questions one what would be what would
it be like if Saddam was still in power
with the region be more stable or less
stable now some people would say it
would be more stable because he was a
hard strong leader and he could stand up
to Iran maybe and in any event it might
have been hell living there but he was
in charge that's one argument the other
argument which
in the end I prefer is that actually he
would be in competition with Iran for
the leadership of radical or extreme
Islam and that we would face an even
more unstable and uncertain future in
that region now what I reflect on this
is the second point I would make when I
look at both Iraq and Afghanistan is
when we took the decision on Afghanistan
virtually everyone agreed on it and we
removed the Taliban very quickly as we
removed Saddam very quickly what has
actually happened since then is that
those forces that we were trying thought
weird if we locked off the head we dealt
with the body I think we now realize
this thing is far deeper its roots go
far deeper and so what happened was
after a period of two or three years of
relative peace and progress suddenly we
now find a situation where people can
seriously say well actually Afghanistan
at the moment is more difficult than
there are now the conclusion I draw from
that which as I say you agree or
disagree with is not well we shouldn't
be there the conclusion I draw is that
I'm afraid this is a deeper and more
fundamental struggle then maybe we
anticipated at the time of 9/11 and that
I'm afraid we have no alternative but to
see it through until we secure victory
and the reason I think that ultimately
and where I think there is a huge
distinction between this situation and
other situations in your history and
mine is that we are not occupying powers
in Iraq and Afghanistan that don't have
consent from the people to help them on
the contrary when there was an election
in Attica
people came out and voted when there was
an election in Iraq they came out and
voted so in my view if we now leave
those people who desperately need to be
allowed to function in the way they won
first of all we let them down ok but
also if I'm right in the roots of this
thing at very deep we allow those roots
to flourish and grow and that after all
is what happened in Afghanistan that was
then visited on America and 9/11 so you
know that's where I I see this but you
know the single thing that's most
important about this debate is that
people understand this is not easy on
either side and I used to say to people
continually
that I refuse to condemn as sort of you
know peaceniks or idiots people who took
a different view from me and all I ask
from those who do take a different view
for me is that they don't think I'm
either badly motivated or I like war for
the sake of war these are big
fundamental political decisions that
have to be taken and I took them to the
best of my ability and I believed in
them but if I'm gonna sit here and say
to you you know do you ever have any
doubt or hesitation of course any leader
who takes these decisions has doubt and
hesitation but in the end you have to do
what you believe is right and that's
well let's take you off the hot seat and
talk about another hot problem which is
one that I know consumes also a great
deal of your passion and that is the
problem of global warming the I know
that you also decided to vote a good
part of your effort to trying to broker
a deal among the largest emitters of
carbon and and to help bring that to
some kind of satisfactory resolution on
a global agreement toward carbon
reduction next year at the Copenhagen
meetings in December what do you see is
the prospects for getting a global deal
do you think it's possible and what
would be the shape of it if so and I
think it's possible and and I think it's
essential but you know I think it comes
down to one very simple question which
is can you get a deal with America and
China in it
I think my advice at this stage would be
not to try and replicate the Kyoto
process Kyoto was a groundbreaking
agreement but you know I think we've got
to be very honest about this with
ourselves you know 190 countries sitting
around a table and trying to negotiate
an agreement and say right you America
have got to do this and you China have
got to do that it's not gonna work like
that what is important is established
when I had the leadership of the GA a
process where you've got the g8
countries plus five which is plus China
and India Brazil Mexico and South Africa
and between those 13 countries and you
can add in Australia and Korea and you
get to the major emitter economies
that's 15 and it's about almost 80% of
the emissions in the world if you can't
get agreement between those 15 and in
particular those two and then without
sort of disrespecting any of the other
countries the fact if people sometimes
say to me a hundred and forty countries
of agree Kyoto and I said well that's
absolutely fine except they only amount
to fifteen percent of the emissions so
you know it's not really a great deal of
good and and I think what we should do
is we should try and get agreement with
those major countries and we should do
that on this basis if America can
produce some version of of the warner
lieberman bill and that will mean
substantial cuts in emissions for
america so that you peak and start to
reverse emissions going up to 2020 and
if China is prepared to commit as I
think it is to clear energy intensity
targets with a time at which their
emissions will start to Pekin and
down in the future my sense of this is
get everyone to do the maximum they are
reasonably prepared to commit get that
put together in an international
framework get it underway but do not
think that in 2009 when we negotiate
this at Copenhagen next year in 2009 we
can spell out exactly what will happen
all the way up to 2050 you know it's
it's absurd realize that there will be
an evolving process over the next few
years so get the best deal that we can
now and then have a process of
re-evaluation and reassessment in the
years to come because the one thing we
know is this we don't know which
technologies will be the groundbreaking
technologies but if you get the right
framework of incentives there will be
such groundbreaking technologies and you
know if that happens then you will want
to adjust your international agreement
as you move along so my view very
clearly of this is that a global deal is
essential the evidence is now clear on
any precautionary principle you would
act the important thing is to get a
global framework get it underway and
provide that certainty and clarity of
direction so that business and industry
who will develop the science and
technology you know know the direction
in which policy is heading and but time
is running out for this this is this is
going to be really really tough but it's
really really necessary and if we don't
do it next year and I don't know when we
will so I I agree with much of what
you're saying but and I do think 2050 is
a long way out but I would you know I
would suggest from the point of view of
economics that you need to have
increasingly stringent carbon caps over
some fairly long time
in order to elicit the investment in new
technologies if people aren't going to
if these caps go in place in 2012 when
Kyoto expires caps that only run to 2020
may not be long-term enough to elicit
big investments in biofuels and and and
you know we truly improved wind and
solar technologies it may take five
years to develop and then you would have
enough time to reap the payoff here's
the problem there from a political point
of view because what you say is
absolutely right but if you give the
politicians the opportunity I mean I say
this you know about my own profession as
it were but if you give them the
opportunity to commit themselves to
goals in 2050 I promise you will get an
amazing and radical set of ambitions
that will be declared that should happen
in 2050 where as we sit here in 2008 if
you don't get them tied down to a time
where they might just think that people
would still remember it was their
responsibility you'll find a lot tougher
to do so I agree with you you shouldn't
stop at 2020 but if you don't have
interim goals oh I'm thinking of annual
goals that are increasingly ya know I
think you can do that but run it for
2030 at least hey yeah I agree but the
important thing is to get this process
underway and if you end up in a
situation where you're trying to
negotiate immense detail over any
lengthy period of time you will find if
you're not careful that the the devil of
that detail will stop the initial
political agreement and my view is that
the key thing is to get them agreed next
year so that's why you know I think and
I say this with a again great respect to
the NGO movement and to the green
movement and so on but you've got to
take this issue
back into the realms of practical
politics and the practical politics is
particularly with the economic situation
at the moment is that you're not going
to force countries to do something they
think they just can't do you know
whatever people say it isn't gonna
happen and you're not gonna force
America in my view to get in this part
of the global deal whoever comes to
power unless China is in that deal right
so you're gonna have to have a situation
in which you don't make the best the
enemy of the good get the maximum people
can reasonably do which if the Americans
are doing something along the lines of
Warner Lieberman and China is doing the
energy intensity targets it's likely to
come out with soon that will give you
enough to get it going the Europeans
have got their trading system the
Japanese would come in with a cap and
trade behind that and then you've got it
under way and if you get it under way
that in my view is the single most
important thing and and then we will
find as we found at Britain actually we
now have more people employed in
environmental technology than in coal
steel and shipbuilding put together and
tripled they can get India in the deal
there they claim that they're the only
one of the large economies that are
currently below the level of emission
that we need to get to let's say by 2050
so their argument is we shouldn't have
to do anything for a long while
yeah and I understand that totally and
but obviously because they want to
industrialize that's gonna change so
here's the thing and this is the race
against time on this China and India
will industrialize by moving hundreds of
millions of people each of them hundreds
of millions from a rural economy to an
industrialized economy right China will
build the next ten years more power
stations than Europe has built since the
Second World War
right it's I think the 70 new
international airports now here's the
thing China and India as they increase
their power provision
at the moment 80% of it or there abouts
is going to come from coal-fired
provision so again in my view the
practical decision-making we're gonna
have to have will be around how we
upscale carbon capture and storage
issues to do again very controversial
with nuclear power how we develop the
best renewable energy quickly and how we
deal with the fact that unless we're in
a position to share that technology with
China and India as they grow even if we
bring our emissions down their emissions
are going to to make up the difference
and you know just before I left office
in one of these little interesting facts
they sometimes give you four my prime
minister's question day we worked out
that if you shut down the whole of the
UK so we had zero emissions the growth
in Chinese emissions would make up the
difference within 18 months so that's
why other stuff China in the deal
amazing so let's talk a minute about
your experience as a politician it's a
presidential election year here in the
United States and we have is it I
noticed that you mean other people and
other parts of the world are paying
attention we we've had one party in
power for twenty of the last 28 years
and you of course of the man who
defeated a party that had been in power
for 18 consecutive years from position
of being in the the party of the left
side of the spectrum how did you do it
what's the secret how does how does a
candidate from the left wing
neutral question yeah it's an empirical
question it's not a statement of
position this is as a matter of general
abstract principle and nothing to do
with any particular events that may be
going on at the present time and our
election campaign is four weeks long so
my theory of this is always veena I mean
I think our first election victory not
the size of it but the fact of it was in
part because they've been 18 years of
successive conservative government and
but I think the very large majority we
got and then again in 2001 and then even
we're the majority of over 60 of over
all the other parties in 2005 I think
there's latter two election victories
were something to do with the political
position we we have and that this may be
vigorously disputed by any Republican
and conservative people but my my theory
of this is the four progressive parties
to win and they have to be in the center
they have to be absolutely rooted in the
center and they have to be good and this
may seem extremely unfair and often did
people in in the Labor Party but you
could and we did have in the UK
situations in which conservative parties
won from a very enormous radical
right-wing position but we never really
had a situation where we have a one from
a radical left-wing position and I just
think you know the most important thing
as well when you're fighting an election
nowadays is to realize people are
prepared to change far more than they
ever were before you know I I fought my
first election in it was in a
by-election in a place called beckons
fielding in in England and May 1982 and
I got completely slaughtered I mean we
were in the middle of the Falklands War
and my father-in-law who's very
left-wing actor and decided to come and
help me with the campaigning
and we used to have this great sort of
battle bus that we drove through trying
to whip up support for the Labour cause
and the whole country had gone really
jingoistic I mean if you remember at the
time poll they were absolutely you know
fully in favor of the war and everything
and I made the mistake of allowing him
to get near the sound system and I never
forget driving through through beckons
fielders that people were coming out and
waving the Union Jackson shouting in my
bus and not very kind things and
suddenly on to the amplifier come John
and Yoko singing give peace a chance and
you know I learned a lot of things from
that election but I used to kind of go
and knock on the door then and sort of
I'd sort of knock on the door and I'd
apologetically kind of ask if people
might you know if they really thought
about it and please don't think I'm
pushing but could they think of possibly
supporting me as a Labour candidate when
I then went to fight the election in
1983 in the seat that I then had which
is a solid labour seat in the north of
England County Durham used to knock on
the door in those days and if you said
to them will you be voting labour they'd
say are you accusing me of of not voting
like are you trying to tell me I might
vote for another party so absolutely
solidly labour were they it was an
insult even to suggest that they might
vote for somebody else those days are
gone you know in politics and probably
not a bad thing either you know those
days have gotten people people will will
drift about far more and the key
therefore in politics today is to be
able to understand first the appeal of
the other party you know never despise
them you know we had a situation where
when in the labour party we were trying
to to make real changes and you know the
public used to was supporting the
changes that we were making in the
labour party and
forget going to a meeting at the Labor
Party where there were people sort of
shouting at me outside with it and there
was a people with the placards out which
said no compromise with the electorate
you know which is not an immediately
election winning slogan and you know
that sense in a political party can
often be more for the progressives you
know they can if they're not careful
they kind of can give a sense they don't
much like their electorate you've always
got to understand why people might feel
attracted to the other side and you've
got to be able to meet them and bring
them over if you don't do that
so the strategy of appealing to the base
to the party base which is sometimes
recently in recent years been highly
touted as a Stratus a successful
strategy for Republicans you're saying
that doesn't work that would not work
for Democrats I don't think it works in
the same way no I maybe I don't
Democrat Republican you guys are the
experts on that but in my own politics
no it doesn't work in that way if you
appeal to your party base you're liable
to some one-way ticket to our position
you've got a you've got to appeal beyond
that and also I think increasingly
nowadays as well people want their
political leaders not to be the leader
of a party or a faction they want to
think of them as a leader of a country
and now to take you perhaps away from
the role as politician downed heroes
educator president Levin mentioned that
you're here now for a seminar and I know
education has always been a big theme
for you
so on a slightly more philosophical note
for my generation out here in the
audience how is your education shaped to
you what do you think we should be
taking to be global leaders to be global
citizens to give back to the global
community I mean I when I was asked
before I came to power in 1997 while my
three priorities were if I was elected
prime minister I said education
education and education and I know
myself
I mean I'm not very clever so education
was for me this is the thing that opened
up a world of possibility you know and I
think there's no greater gift that we
can give people in education and there
is no greater injustice than to refuse
people the opportunity to get education
and it's why I believe it in our own
countries but I also believe of people
in Africa and for people in different
parts of the world who may never get the
chance that we get and you know think of
the ideas that we're subject to and the
horizons that are opened up for us as a
result of Education and it's a real
privilege to have it and it's a
privilege that we should extend as far
as possible in the world because I
believe in it how is never a very good
student but I did understand how much
education gave to me and I think one of
the great things that that people
actually like you can do and your other
fellow students is to having benefited
from this fantastic education here to
make sure and whatever walk of life you
then go into you're trying to do your
best to spread the benefit of that
education to other people do you looking
back at the very beginnings of your
you're moving to education move to
university etc and thinking of your
school days we were wondering whether
you know there was a particular school
teacher could influenced you or
particular writings literature some
characters some way in which many years
later when you're in office as you know
John garrison I teaching this grant
strategy course which is to say have
people read great texts get good
teachers now because you won't have time
in the next 25 years but when you were
up in a position of influence you think
of of Gibbon or Macaulay or a great
teacher you had who taught you about
moral precepts or practical politics
I was actually really lucky in the at
school in fact the main thing that most
of my teaches someone was reminding me
yesterday in the biography that's
written on me that they said that their
overwhelming sense amongst the people
who taught me was that I was a complete
pain in the backside as a as a student
and I said to them what the feeling was
mutual
I am I actually funnily enough it was
when I got to university that I started
not within some of the formal structures
of teaching but when I was mixing with
people from different walks of life
there was someone a religious person who
made a huge impression on me and then
there were some postgraduate students
that open my eyes to the possibility of
politics and so on and actually when I
think back in the teachers that I had in
my life I had some really good they're
misunderstand had some great teachers at
school talking about literature and
history but then the great thing about
university is when you come and you mix
with all sorts of different people and
they challenge your preconceived
thinking you know because I came to
university with no politics or have I
had any politics conservative politics
and you know because my dad was a
conservative owner then people opened my
mind to new and different thoughts and
that's the fascinating thing about what
you're engaged in here you know it's
actually about opening your mind and
about the endless fascination and
curiosity for knowledge you know and and
and I was I was so lucky to get that
opportunity you know I've never
forgotten the impact that it that it
made on me and the constituency I
represented up in the north of England
was quite a poor constituency and the
overwhelming majority of the young
people would never have gone to
university and the really interesting
thing was when
for various reasons you know we were
able to take some young young people on
to do internships with us and sometimes
it was the first time that they had ever
got a sense of what they could achieve
of the potential of their own mind and
to watch that happen with a young person
and suddenly they think no the things I
can do and the things I want to do and
the things I want to know and there are
things that I can learn about and there
are things actually that I can give to
other people that is a wonderful thing
so I think education if you an educated
world in in my view will be a peaceful
world and a prosperous one and so I
think there's nothing more important you
know we will have a new president the
United States in January and that that
president I think is going to chart a
new direction for the country one way or
another so I wonder what advice
regardless of who wins what advice would
you give to the next American president
about America's proper role in the world
I mean how how should America behave in
the world in the global community with
what directions should stake out what
instruments should it use easy one I've
got a tough question coming up later
I think the first thing that I would do
is I wouldn't I wouldn't misunderstand
the position of America in the world
today hey there is a view that you know
America's forfeit of its position and so
on and so forth the thing about America
is that people want America to take
responsibility for the world's problems
but they also want to complain about
America too and that's totally natural
because you're the most powerful country
in the world and actually one of the
interesting things that's happened to
China over these past months is that
suddenly people kind of look at China as
a power as well as a developing nation
and they start to get a bit more you
know the fingers wagged a bit more atom
and that's the way it happens but I
think the single most important thing
for America to do now is to realize that
as this century develops and we have to
share power with the rising East because
China will become in is immensely
powerful it will come even more so and
then behind it India and other nations
of the world that if we want our value
system which is about freedom and
democracy and equal opportunity and so
on if we want that to be the dominant
value system of the 21st century we have
to give leadership but we also have to
listen as well so
I think that it will be important that
America continues to lead on the big
security questions of the day but I also
think when the rest of the world is
saying climate change matters that
America listens when the rest of the
world is saying the Middle East peace
process is really important America
listens when the rest of the world is
saying we want justice as a concept to
go alongside freedom and democracy it's
important that America listens and I
think for America now it has the
opportunity to lead and to listen and if
it gets that balance right it can lead
the agenda which will be not just about
the things that matter to America but
the things to matter to others and it
will be able to express through that
agenda the value system that we hold
dear and that I genuinely believe is
Universal in nature that is not about
Western countries or European countries
or America that is genuinely the
universal values of the human spirit but
that is the battle and it can't be won
in the old way it can't be won just by
saying we're America and that's what we
want because the world that's developing
is a world in which power is going to be
shared and the best way to share it is
to balance the leading with the
listening develop that agenda express
the values through it and then I think
we will find that our value system has
the chance to shape the 21st century and
not be overwhelmed by it hear hear
you know there's not a single person in
this room who believes your statement
that you were a lousy student he's given
us plenty of livin elephant you've given
us plenty of evidence to the contrary
your presence here honors us we're
thrilled to have you a part of our
community I'm going to ask one last
question the really hard one okay for a
former rock musician tell us Beatles or
Rolling Stones
do you know that was the question they
used to have to answer when I was
younger and it was really unfair because
I was used to say the Rolling Stones
because if you didn't say the stones the
girlfriends just that the truth I'm
afraid and sad to say is really it was
the Beatles
thank you for educating us and thank you
all for coming afternoon
you